Neko did you see the gift
[Music]
it sounds really complicated
[Applause]
[Music]
give me a friend go and Jimmy goes into
this chat it comes I'm Freddie Freddie
you need to see this
[Music]
stepping in my office
but you think I'm scared of a little
hairs getting ripped on my toes a lot of
work
[Music]
right
it's tough man
[Music]
we change your life
I'm Jake Watson I'll be your host
I just gotta lean into this
[Music]
now is he the nicest unity tonight
you're cooking don't want the wind to
blow out your fire
it's never gonna work there is merely
one Jam
[Music]
Merlin's pants Ceaser's goats
fiddlesticks
snickerdoodles mother Schmucker
right
[Music]
I think it'll happen and then it happens
the Edit needs to be done like now
[Music]
half our computers don't work camera the
last time I pulled an all-nighter this
video is turning into a nightmare maybe
every hour that goes by I fail even more
[Music]
supposed to be the easiest shot
right the sandwiches are the best Jetta
makes them
[Music]
now that's what we call art when you're
cooking you don't want the wind to blow
out your fire now I know this isn't the
regular video that we put out in this
channel but when I came into work this
morning Carmichael was so excited I was
like Nico did you see the gift I didn't
see the gap and he showed me the gift
and it's what you just saw there the
incredible animation was done by a guy
named Garrett Ricci Garrity's YouTube
channel it's a goop to five to six here
it made this incredible animation sent
it over to us
you know what Garrett it is so good then
we need to add some sound and we need to
add some music we put this up on the
channel ASAP and here it was like that
would be cool so here it studio show get
some love in the comments down below
come on check out his channel go for it
just has three videos on there one look
like just dancing goats whatever go get
some thumbs ups
anyways consider subscribing